Salut
L'heure est grave...
Parce que sa fait pu***n de plus de 12 heures que j'attends de faire cette vidéo
Je vous ai, hier soir, aux alentours de 20 heures (dommage j'etais pas la 😭)
J'adore donner des détails inutiles
Fait un tweet qui vous demandait de faire des photos montages MARRANTS avec les photos ci-dessous
Donc... y'a... on montre du doigt
On fait le super saiyan
On tient quelque chose on sait pas quoi
*rire*
Elle est humiliante cette photo...
...même si tu fais pas de montage...
...elle est terrible
Et une où on engueule quelqu'un
Et dans mon deuxième tweet c'était ces photos la
Voilà une belle indication
Un doigt ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
*longue reflexion*
Un ninja..Un vrai ninja
Et à la recherche de quelque chose
J'ai LUTTÉ, littéralement pour ne pas aller sur twitter et regarder mes mentions.. J'ai galéré..Je.. mourrais d'envie de voir ces photos montages que vous avez fait
Mesdames et messieurs, c'est parti pour observer vos photos montages !
Mec j'attends ça depuis...
*Surpris* Farod qui s'est déchainé
Tes photos m'ont inspiré
Ce matin chez Squeezie
J'ai terminé mes vidéos pour lundi, mardi, mercredi et euh ...
Oh non p*tain non j'ai pas fini un montage
Hé
Pss Clément
Clément qui s'est transformé en Farod.. D'ailleurs
Attends mais ta fais une BD ?!
*Rigole*
*voix qui se casse d'émotion* Mais Farod il s'est déchainé
Il a fait une BD le mec !
Fini mon montage avant demain
Je compte sur toi
J'peux pas désolé vieux
D'où tu refuses ?!
Ok pardon...
Mais c'est quoi ça ?
ça ?
Bah un handspin...
*Rigole*
Mais mec c'est GÉNIAAAAL
Excusez moi, pardon, j'étais obligé de crier mais mec, il s'est tellement fait chier
Et hop un stagiaire de moins
Il a utilisé cette photo à tellement juste titre
En espérant que le prochain ... ait un meilleur prénom . The end
*Applaudis*
Mec !
On a commencé par.. le meilleur ! C'est sur qui a pas mieux que ça !
Farod mec tu t'es...
Franchement...
...Farod
*S'abonne*
Voilà !
C'est mérité
Vlog chez Dorcel , Squeezie découvre une nouvelle passion
*Rigole*
Y'a juste un..
Un problème de proportion
Et de détourage
Sur cette photo
Mais sinon... c'était pas... l'idée était là
Et bah ! Et Dorcel qui répond
Non mais attendez, sa suffit !
L'histoire n'est pas celle que vous croyez
*Rigole*
Ohlala, on en est la, j'aime bien
Tire sur mon doigt
*Rigole*
Putain vous êtes pas mes abonnés pour rien !
Je vous aime !
Vive le prout !
*Rigole*
C'est pas mal ça ! L'attaque des titans. Je me suis transformé en titan colossal
Putain ! Hé vous vous êtes faites chier !!
J'aime beaucoup
Bienvenue dans le nouveau Meuporg World Of Squeezie
Choisissez votre classe
Inspecteur
Guerrier Saiyan
Épéiste
Wesh
Ninja
Très mignon
Je choisirais personnellement
le ninja
Cette info n'intéresse personne mais souvenez vous du début de la vidéo ce qu'on a dit
*flashback* j'adore donner des détails inutiles
voilà
J'y ai passé toute la soirée
J'ai intitulé mon oeuvre : THE FLOOR IS PLACEMENT DE PRODUIT
*Rire*
P*tain mais y'en a qui sont tellement doués !
Vous êtes trop fort
Ah mec, les vieilles têtes déformées de Mcfly et Carlito derrière
Bravo !!
Vraiment puissant
C'est fort !
Qui sont ces dames qui font des photos comme ça , ça n"a pas de sens
Ah la bâtarde !
Merci pour toutes ces..
Pas toi !
superbes vidéos on vous aime
Hey ! C'était il y a plusieurs jours la vidéo pour me faire redescendre sur terre
C'est pas celle là
Là c'est fini c'est bon je vais bien
En référence au logo de Nike, c'est très très beau
Vous avez énormément d'imagination, c'est vraiment beau
Simple, efficace
Send Nudes
Pas mal !
Et oubliez pas le follow, faites comme Squeezie, merci
Oh le mec fait sa pub en plus de ça
Le mec fait sa pub
Oooh les retrouvailles
Oooh, ça me brise le coeur ce que tu viens de faire
Mais c'est très bien fait
Marc Dorcel qui nous...
...tweet une photo de cul
Ah d'acc !
Mais vous n'avez pas honte
Mais c'est des zigotos chez Marc Dorcel mec
Attend !
*Rigole* Les bâtards !
Mais n'en profitez pas pour m'humilier
Non mais après si je puisse me permettre, le respect était dans cette direction
Plutôt que dans...
Mais bon après bon
Oooh Squeezie 10 minutes & 1 seconde
C'est magnifique
Oh putain !
10 minutes et 1 secondes
Oooh en référence, en référence au fait que quand ta vidéo fait 10 minutes tu peut mettre 2 pubs au lieu d'une
C'est ça ?
Putain mais c'est malin
J'avais même pas vu la référence
Puisque dans le vrai film le mec reste pas coincé 10 minutes en 2 cailloux
Si sinon ce serait nul et en plus ça ne sortirai pas au cinéma
Bien sûre avec JCVD hein
Pas mal
La nouvelle arme ultime de Kim Jong-Un c'est
Très bien trouvé
Attend mais là il n'y a plus d'effort quoi, il n'y a plus aucun effort là
Dans ce photo-montage
Regarde ça il n'y a rien qui va
C'est fou
Oooh c'est beau
Ce celui-ci est très très beau
Squeezie et sa femme, mec franchement c'est pas sympa de mettre la vie privée des gens en avant comme ça
C'est vraiment pas sympas
Quand Squeezie voit une fille trop belle, réaction bizarre
Alors Marion Chedevergne tu as 8 ans et demi c'est sûr c'est obligatoire
Lol désolé il y a encore le fond vert
Mec ! Mais tu peux pas ça ça
Tu peux pas faire ça, tu peux pas faire ton montage et dire désolé il y a encore le fond vert
Ca ne marche pas !
Est-ce que tu as vu Avenger Avenger
Est-ce que tu as vu un fond vert avec marqué "désolé il y a encore le fond vert"
Non !
On a un nouveau Cloud pour le prochain Final Fantasy
Et ben mec je vais en parler à Square Enix
Et il y a moyen qu'il me colle un procès
Vous n'auriez pas vu l'inspiration ? Parce que j'en manque vraiment là
Oh putain !
Oooh Squeezie rencontre 3D Squeezie
What the fuck mec
Tu t'es fait chier à me modéliser
Un peu mon décor en 3D, bon pas les figurines fallait pas fallait pas abuser quand même
Mais mec c'est fou
Oooh c'est beau
Il rencontre Jackie Chan, ça tourne mal
C'est beau, très très belle affiche
Attend t'as carrément reconstitué mon bras qui à la base est coupé quoi
C'est fou !
Putain ! Allez voir ce film c'est énorme, c'est énorme
*Homme qui tombe
*Homme qui rigole
*Bruit de Ninja Squeezie
*Encore ninja Squeezie
Mec ça me fait rire, c'est grave
Je sais pas ce qui est le pire, la qualité du montage ou le fait que ça m'est fait rire
Et bien mes amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo où je regarde vos photo-montages
Et bien merci d'avoir pris le temps de les faires, c'est hyper sympas
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous a plu
Il y a eu des trucs, il y a eu des perles hein !
Il y a eu Farod, il a eu celle-ci qui m'a qui m'a
Fait vomir
Que vous avez fait un truc de merde ou un truc bien
En vrai c'est c'est cool, vous avez pris le temps de faire quelque chose
C'est très mignon
Ça valait le coup d'attendre une nuit pour regarder tout ça en vidéo
J'ai passé un bon moment
Allez à tous pour une prochaine vidéo
Je vous dit au revoir, attention
*siffle*
Abonnez vous à Squeezie